b b b this is perfect I don't want you
to feel called out Nikki but I do an
orange no you're the only person I know
that can p oh God yeah yeah look at you
wearing orange today this a rust this is
a brown rust no I the first episode of
the show of f boy Island I'm in an
orange dress like for the intro and it's
horrific I called this one's okay but
don't want you to feel called
out of all the things of all the things
you would ever ask me to cut can you
please just show your makeup bag really
quick oh my God I am so obsessed with
women's makeup bags and the wet Market
inside that fucking bag this is where Co
began I look at looked at it I was like
what's in there and then mine is dirty
brush oh my God yours is bad too are
those toothbrushes that you use in your
mouth sometimes I use them on my lips to
exfoliate my lips when they get dry but
there is a smegma lining on this that is
so the brushes are touching whatever the
I have no protection for my brushes I
don't clean my brushes how do we not
have pink eye all the time I uh it's
yeah it's uh it's revolting in here I
just want I have like a jar of um
tanning
stuff is it are you know when
you're
show I have a busy bre wait he Cosmetics
I mean she wait what is the brown brush
from the 20s this is like for your hair
because I don't like to have like an
actual because it doesn't it look like
looks like Hitler's mustache
brush what is that I had a special order
from Amazon it's just like a little
purse brush you know probably B's Hair
it's probably not vegan it's probably a
bad vegan and then um some
Xanax dirty dirty brushes why am I
obsessed just like I mean it's all CRA
it's like crap like look at that it's
it's this is like I'm opening up my
labia yeah no this for this is um uh
what was that bitch's name that had all
the shit Mary Poppins oh yeah it I mean
the fact that I've Consolidated this is
all that I use on ey drops that will
never be opened that I have never opened
three loose toothbrushes not one not two
three let's find the most random object
in there that doesn't belong I mean the
toothbrushes four toothbrushes no
toothpaste whatsoever well that's
actually good to have because when
you're on the road and you actually
forget your toothbrush you you could use
those yeah a lot of tops and no lot lot
of like just tops of things so many like
things with every every end has hair
coming out of it this why we're meant to
be friends hold that up isn't it's
you've I've got the tops for there's a
lid for every
pot this is so sad in here it's
devastating it's so depressing I think
it's like you kind of like I just I just
want people to know that there's no
level of a success that a comedian let's
say female comedian can achieve where
they will have self-respect in any
capacity where they will stop living
like this what are we supposed to have
though like it how is it not am I
supposed to clean out the inside of my
part like I just can't I think so this
goes on our face our I mean when I think
about your like skin is an organ and
it's like absorbing everything that you
put on it it's devastating when you
think about it just just painting on
dirt every day I just love the story so
people love me I just love the story
that our makeup bags tell of just
touring meets hosting fboy Island meets
going from show to show to show and that
thing is so aart like that's as
important to me as my phone like that
that bag of makeup it's it's my lifeline
I can't imagine the other day I was
going to get a um micro needling and
then they were like you can't wear
makeup for 48 hours and I was like well
I have to be on stage tonight I'm not
and I was telling my boyfriend like I
just got Botox I didn't do the micro
needling he's like why not just go on
stage tonight without makeup and I was
like so you're the comedian yeah like I
know you love me for who I am kind of
I'm wearing makeup like as I talk to you
babe like I'm nervous to be around you
without it like I can't I can't it's so
funny do you ever think about how men
like will go they won't wear makeup to
their wedding like men don't wear makeup
to the most important day of their life
yet women have to wear makeup to the DMB
not have to I know that lots of women
opt out also I must say one of the most
hurtful things that happens to me is
when I'm not wearing makeup and and you
get recognized in public and I'm like
wait I go you're not I go I'm fuck you
there's not a lot of a
I get so offended every time I get
recognized without makeup it's I have a
joke about it literally where I'm like I
am going to tell her that's so rude that
you said that about Nikki Glazer she's
much hotter than this so but it makes me
think like wait so I look the same and I
think I'm like Incognito without makeup
because I look so different when I put
makeup on I'm like there she is I think
I made different face I complet I really
feel like I can get away with anything
without makeup on but um yeah apparently
my face is my face
something nice about that what's the one
thing you can't leave if you could only
pick one my new one is eyebrows for some
reason eyebrows are so essential but I
think if I was like I always think like
on Survivor if you have to be on TV and
you're like bringing one makeup item to
like the island it would probably be
like a m it'd probably be mascara
interesting that's the one thing that
makes your face not look like a man's
because men don't have like long like if
you're drawing a smiley face and you're
like okay make that smiley face a woman
you don't like draw it holding less
money or whatever draw a bubble with
like like blah blah
blah you like how you draw eyelashes
tear drop
yeah wait tell me about this so okay so
you're still with same guy yes and how
does touring in your wild schedule
affect being with this guy this has been
how long it's been 10 years off and on
but we're really on right now so we'll
be off soon that's my joke um yeah it's
uh it's yeah it's been off and which I
like I recommend people are like how
don't get back with your ex I don't know
how people don't like we he's changed
and we we always like end up choosing
each other we go out and date other
people then we um we choose each other
so we've been together he just moved in
like a two months ago for the first time
and um it's great like I leave all the
time he comes on the road with me a lot
though cuz he's like producing my
special so he's out on the road like
taking notes and stuff and and um yeah
it's suicide notes he's like she's never
going to marry me what am I
doing is that that am I giving that Vibe
why are there so many men in the front R
of her
shows like I am I realize I am the one
that's scared of commitment like I
always thought that I was wanting a
relationship so bad you accuse other
people of is who you
are like I just I just always fell into
the Trope of like the woman who like is
longing for the guy to like her like we
fall into these archetypes that and
especially in my even in my act like I
look at my act and I'm just like why
won't he marry me like back in the day
like talking about him and how he won't
commit which is true he wouldn't he was
scared of it but now he's not and I'm
like let's slow down here it's only but
40 is too young to get married I really
think that's true yeah I don't I don't
disagree with you I do everything
another 50 years that's a really long
time to be with someone I do but what I
will say about marriage is sorry hot
take like it doesn't have to last you
know what I mean agreed I don't think
Hugh Jackman's marriage is a failure
that is one of the most successful
things I've ever heard in my life and
people are like it failed I'm like no I
don't think Kim Kardashian's first
marriage was a failure the one lasted
like a few get married for 6 weeks who
cares totally it's I think that like
there's a certain point especially
you're living together where a breakup
is kind of just as bad as a divorce if
you like already have something in
writing like we're just going to leave
with what we came with you're still
moving out you're still like everybody
knows you were together you're still
like dealing with like parceling stuff
up so my thing is like if you're going
to be together for six years you might
as well get married and get divorced who
cares right you know wait hold on if
you're together for six years you might
as well get married and divor I'm saying
like if you're living together for 10
years and like yeah but we don't want to
get get married it's like this breakup
is going to be just as bad oh yeah
there's no difference both close to each
other's parents you're both going to
have to you both spent went to the flea
market and got that's why I but I I say
don't get married because I just don't
breakups are hard enough I don't want to
call a lawyer like I don't want to have
to like get to know a lawyer and be like
hi I'm Nikki like I just don't want to
like have to go buy like a pencil skirt
for court or whatever like I just don't
I worry about like what I'm going to
wear to my divorce and that's why I
don't want to get married but it's it's
I love that you're such a celebrity that
you think your divorce is going to be
like
televised I don't I just assume you have
to go to court no you you can do it over
Legal Zoom in 5 minutes I definitely
don't think what am I going to wear a
cord is Johnny Deb's lawyer available I
just don't want to like call a lawyer
like I just don't want to have to like
deal with anything else like breakups
are just yeah and I would love in every
relationship I've been in if I've hooked
up with something three times and I want
to break up with them I'm like I need to
get a can a lawyer can someone else do
this I would love for someone else to
handle all that stuff that's why um
couple therapy is so amazing it's just
you have a mediator you have someone
there that's like can just witness it
and it can't it doesn't go off the rails
I save every argu my boyfriend knows
when I'm upset cuz I'm like so when do
you think we could go to therapy next
week like it's I get like scared even
asking him about there because he's like
well what's wrong and I'm like can we
just wait till we get there I don't want
to I don't want to confront it now I'm I
know I'm right but if I make my case
without her I'm going to come off wrong
I'm that's it I that's it and and I know
I'm going to get too emotional and it's
going to spiral and I'm um what I'm
saying is going to get lost in how I'm
saying it yes or something but that's
really that to me is when they say like
relationships take work I cannot stand
that phrase I'm like I have a job I
don't I'm good on that but that's the
work is like the Restraint of I don't
want to hurt you I don't want to say
something I don't mean or I don't want
what I'm saying to get lost in how I'm
saying it or like the way you've cast me
in the past because I've made mistakes
in the past that saying this now is
going to S you know what I mean your
voice is always in my head because I
remember one time we were talking about
that book getting to I do and all the
things we learned from it but we you
said that um we I was talking about like
so if if I'm driving he's driving the
car are and like I know that a way to
get there 10 minutes earlier like just
don't say it and you're like what does
it matter like what is 10 minutes when
it's like you're ruining his self-esteem
for the night and it's like it's going
to take more time in the end it's
emotionally longer yes I keep so many
shortcuts to myself driving with your
voice in my head um and you you you've
saved me a lot of trouble because it
isn't worth the fight to be like I know
a better way what are you doing going
this way like no are you saving 10
minutes if you fight for 45 yes and
that's but that's why I like therapy is
that you have to get the argument
settled in an hour and I think that
sometimes these things can draw draw out
way too long um my boyfriend really
likes to be understood and like which
everyone does but really likes to like
say the thing that he's upset about over
and over until and I can repeat it and
go yes I just heard you and then he says
it again like do you do AO what's that
ao's like Game Changer Harville Hendrick
um the book getting the love you want
really helped me a lot just in the
beginning when I was in relationships
with people that c caus me adrenaline
excuse me sorry that's my main pregnancy
thing is just burping on camera and
making men fall out of love with me how
did I make my personality more repellent
to Reddit users um but is that you know
before you heal yourself we're attracted
to people with the negative qualities of
our primary caretaker because it's such
a familiar neurochemistry you know for
better for worse and that when you're in
argu with argument with someone
especially since our brains move so fast
like as you're stating your case I'm
already coming up with my response I'm
already coming up with my defense or I'm
just like judging what you're saying
instead of listening so you have to
repeat it back so if you say like I feel
insecure that you have all these men at
your shows that are taking pictures with
you and grabbing your stomach or
whatever whatever it is you go okay what
I'm hearing is that at my shows you feel
insecure you have to repeat it you have
and then he goes that's not what I'm
saying you go you can't respond until
you've repeated it back to the other
person yes okay and that is what I that
is what I try to do but I again like go
well what I'm hearing is that you're
like annoyed by the fact that press two
times the speed like I'm listening to a
podcast like I just sometimes I just
know where it's going and I don't
because I but he does acknowledge you
think faster than I do you talk faster
than I do I need more time to like
process things and I think that a a a
therapist like mediates it and kind of
goes okay like let's get to like it's
better than me being like get to the
point yeah yeah but it's it's there and
then when someone puts pressure on you
like that you can't get to the point
because then you're like you know like
you're giving him the light oh and
you're bombing and you're like how but I
don't have enough time to get out of
this fucking trench I built myself into
yeah but I also think like we tend to
because we're very cerebral analytical
people we also tend to like talk too
much about shit too it's just like you
know I know what that I am so my Kink is
just apologizing at this point that's
all I ever want is to get an apology and
then leave it at that it's okay you
fucked up I'll I'll forgive you and we
can move on like I've been dealing with
this recently where people have been
I've been confronting things and they go
oh sorry but it's actually because and
then the excuses I'm like it's okay that
you fucked up we're allowed to fuck up
and I'm I'm allowed to be upset that you
fucked up but I'm also allowed to I'll
forgive you if you just say sorry that's
all I need I don't need I don't need the
excuses yeah but if they say and don't
mean it you're not going to it's going
to make more resentment I think you and
I sorry but does not I don't like butts
you and I I think are particularly able
to own our own shit almost to a fault
yeah we're able to because I'm such a
this and I'm a this and I'm neurotic and
I probably overthought I'm just trying
to beat everyone to what they're going
to think about me anyway say it again a
different way I'm trying to say to
people what they what they not that what
they want to hear but like I'm trying to
whatever that person's mad at me about I
want to be mad at myself even more and
show them that I'm like repentant and
like I that I hate myself for it just as
much as they do okay let's talk about
that in a second because that irks me a
little bit as someone that loves you um
because I do feel like sometimes we have
those self-limiting beliefs and we're a
little too hard on ourselves sometimes I
feel like we sometimes are um and but
but we'll get to that because I for me
it's like chances are I have a part in
this what are the chances that I don't
have a part in your feelings being 100%
let me just start with hey I'm sorry if
anything I did upset you before you even
tell me what upset you I'm sorry I know
myself I move really fast I have a lot
going on I I fill my bandwidth a lot we
have such a history let me just start by
saying like I'm sorry if I hurt you in
any way yeah and like I didn't mean like
that's all I want is like I I just want
I'm sorry I hurt you and I think people
don't like that excuse of like it it's
almost like taking of like I'm not sorry
for what I did I'm sorry I hurt you all
I don't even care about that I'm s you
to be sorry for what I did just be sad
that you that I'm sad yeah just be sorry
about that like that's I just I don't
maybe I didn't get of that your with my
guy mainly is like I just want you to
be what you did I obviously don't think
you meant it like that would be in if
you meant who I thought was hurting me
on like he's become upset with me before
about things and I'm like I just want
you to know it was by accident like I'm
so sorry you feel this way but it you
know that I would never intentionally
make you feel that way and if you think
that I'm capable of that you need to run
you should leave because I'm a
psychopath that wants you to feel that
way that's crazy and he's been like you
need to say that sometimes to people
though because they don't get that um so
I always assume no one's trying to hurt
my feelings but that I just want them to
acknowledge that they did and that they
they hate that they made me feel that
way that's all I want yeah and I think
it's like excuses kind of take me out of
that and then it gets tricky because
then you also have to take
responsibility for like if it's
hysterical it's historical like if I
feel pain from you you like the other
way too he probably didn't mean to hurt
you I might be having a honic reaction
and sometimes I have to go this is my
problem is I have to go like I'm feeling
hurt I can I take a little bit of a
break I need like a couple hours to just
go eat something to like go hydrate to
like take care of myself to go check my
DMs or whatever I need to do to get
whatever to make sure that I'm not
putting some old shit on you and like it
also helps me to go like first things
first like are we going to break up over
this no if not cuz to me it's always
like that's that's my thing am I leaving
or not I told my boyfriend if you're mad
at me like cuz I I go to he's breaking
up with me anytime he gets mad at me
about anything it's to me like the end
and I start freaking out and I have
abandon and then I start getting clingy
and like needing to fix it right away
and I've just told him like when you're
confronting me about something if you're
upset with me about something if like
we're you know we're mixed we're with
people at dinner and I say something
that kind of upsets you and I can sense
him like being kind of annoyed like do
you make fun of him or no like I I'll
just say something and he'll be like
that's actually not the way it happened
and I can say I can just tell like we're
not going to get into it now but he's
really annoyed with me right now like
does he say that at dinner no he'll just
be like that's not what happened at all
like it'll just be to exaggerate um let
me just let me just finish the story I'm
killing and he's like but he his
argument would be you're not on stage
we're at dinner with my family or
whatever like you didn't need to H be
your family is so much more high
pressure than 5,000 that's a really good
that's a really good point oh my God the
other day like when Taylor Swift was uh
she she did her like um you know concert
movie premiere and she was like in 13
different theaters all night long on the
red carpet it like exhausting night of
press and the next day she's in Kansas
City sit or like it at the chief's game
in the box with his next to his mom I'm
like can this girl get a fucking break
having to be next to her new boyfriend's
mom for a 4our game after that night it
was like her face probably hurts so much
just saying like yeah like I just felt
for her master muscles oh you know that
feeling when you get to finally find the
thing that you've been searching for on
the internet after
sping don't cut that either after
spending
I just got so excited after SP I need
okay this is an ad for Zach do do you
guys have speech therapists on Zach do
let's just got to the
chase I'm talking about the trying to
make a comparison of like how on the
internet you can find whatever you want
right you spend hours researching you
can read thousands of reviews and you
find what you've been looking for say it
was that sex toy made of amethyst that
glows in the dark that vintage
Scientology book I don't know that that
when he come
book whatever it is you find it it
checks literally all of your boxes
everything you need and has five stars
arrives in 48 hours so why is it that
you can get the most random thing from
around the world in just two days but if
you want to see a good doctor it takes
forever to get an appointment I don't
get it American Healthcare hashtag yuck
not to mention by the way how do you
even know if there you wait for a doctor
for three months and you don't even know
if they're good okay those days are over
thanks to Zach do Zach do is a place to
actually find and book great doctors who
actually have amazing reviews many with
appointments available within
24 hours what are we
Scandinavia Zach do is a free app where
you can find amazing doctors and book
appointments online we're talking about
booking appointments with thousands of
top rated patient reviewed doctors and
Specialists you can filter specifically
for the ones that take your insurance
are located near you and treat almost
any condition you are searching four
these doctors all have verified reviews
from actual real patients not Bots the
average weit time to see a doctor on
Zach do is between 24 and 48 hours and
that is it no catch you can even score
same day appointments if you're
hemorrhaging from the face once you find
the doctor you want you book them
immediately few appts away no more
waiting awkwardly in a in a reception
area or on the phone listening to Ena
those days are over you know you guys
know I'm pregnant every time I see a
weird swollen ve and I got to go to Zach
do and get in there and be like am I
dying why do I look like the worm from
Labyrinth and then they handle it
Healthcare in this country is a
nightmare Zach do is not go to Zach
do.com Whitney download the Zach do app
for free then find and book a toprated
doctor today that's sockdoc zooc
do.com Whitney sck
do.com whitne this show is sponsored by
better heal so now that we have a to get
into a doctor to fix your broken ass
body let's talk about your broken ass
brain this episode is sponsored by
better he now the holidays are coming up
and my parents are
dead this is the first holiday season
where I have absolutely no guilt this is
kidding I'm kidding okay this is
probably going to be a tricky holiday
season I'm pregnant I'm hormonal I have
no parents the world is a nightmare the
news is
depressing it it may be one of those
years where it's hard to figure out what
to feel thankful for or maybe you feel
like you you can't celebrate with all
that's going on in the world and you
know what I'm talking about of course
the fact that succession has gone off
the air has been very traumatic for
me this time of year can be a lot and
you know my therapy is working because I
just took a sip of coffee halfway
through my better help
badre with no compunction whatsoever but
look it's normal to feel when the
holidays are coming up sadness anxiety
frustration that you can't you're
already in the mall Thanksgiving and
there's there's Christmas decorations up
the whole thing's very disorienting but
therapy can be a bright spot amidst all
of the stress right something to look
forward to make you feel grounded and
give you the tools to manage all of the
chaos that's going on therapies Chang my
life you guys know this okay once a week
I get to just process my feelings with
someone who won't roll their eyes or
winse when I admit my deepest darkest
secret sometimes I want to talk about my
dreams and I actually want them to be
taken seriously by someone and that
costs
money my therapists will do that because
sometimes in my dreams I make good
points I'm not always conscious when I'm
awake I'm not always making a lot of
sense but my dreams these days I've been
making a lot of sense and my therapist
lets me Purge emotionally I bring all my
feelings to her so I don't throw them
around at other people therapy helps me
to show up into my relationships being
an adult without my inner child running
the show because I have a literal inner
child now I can't have my metaphorical
inner child be involved it's just too
many it's just too many people quite
frankly if you are thinking about
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time no additional charge find
your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com Whitney
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com betterhelp.com
Whitney what I've asked my boyfriend to
do now is just like make some kind of
touch me when we're going through that
so I just know that's my sign that
you're not going to break up with me
over this like cuz I can't I can't ask
for that in the moment and so I'm like
if you just touch me while we're
fighting like hold on to my wrist very
tightly throw me up against the wall
only way I can come yeah um I just need
I need that because I start to freak out
that he's going to leave but I mean
everything is historical with me I mean
like I'm dating my dad 100% like I just
see it much pretty good can I overstep
yes it's a pitch pitch it what would it
do to just be engaged and not have any
plans to get married oh that's what I
want I like really want to engaged for
for 10 years and just having a r there
is talk about all the attention you get
by the way the fact that you haven't
done this yet is shocking it's such a
good idea you get engaged because
everyone's excited about you're holding
a microphone and there's just a giant
diamond on and there's a big display
like everyone's excited for for you
you're just engag and people and and
yeah I'm interested in that but I feel
like we would have to plan the wedding
and I he would want to push along he
making it so that will never happen me
he does look at my tour when I look at
your tour schedule I'm like she just
wants to get engaged and not plan a
wedding smart every weekend take our
biggest fight recently was him being
like so let's talk about a vacation for
us and I'm like I don't want to go on
vacation when I am like done with Tour
all I do is fly I want to just stay home
and he's like wo like I just want to go
away with you and I'm like but what are
we going to do like you're going to want
to like go hiking and like see a volcano
and I like don't want to do that and
he's like oh my God we can do whatever
you want I'm like I just want to be home
and it's like I'm watching a Volcan I'm
watching something explode with black
lava running down her cheeks right now I
know I'm so I don't know what's wrong
with me but um I don't think anything
really there is something that um having
a ring on having a and I'm not saying it
should fix everything I just think once
you've been together for 10 years and
you're still doing the are we in are we
out thing there is a symbolism of having
that engagement ring on that's a little
bit like okay he's not going to put
whatever amount of money into this like
there's just something about it that's a
little bit it matures you in an odd way
and it gets you out of that that sounds
like Whitney trying to sell me on buying
a house like started an engagement ring
promo code Whitney K Jewelers um but
there those are like those are very
healing things no you're not wrong I
think it would be fun cuz there's still
like you go out in public and you're not
wearing a ring there's just something
about it like just the idea of being
like I'm engaged like there's just
something there's like I think living
together did that for me I'm not I'm I'm
not like scared I'm only scared he's
going to leave me when he's mad at me
and then like it goes away right away
like I'm not like right now in this
moment there's no like this guy is like
so committed to me there's no fear like
it's it's only a thing that comes up
when there's like what did you just say
like a thing like that if anyone ever
does that to to me I just think they're
never going to talk to me yet like you
could do it to me and be like hey if you
were to go like hey can I talk to you
about something I'd be like Whitney's
never going to speak like that's the
fire alarm that goes off my head is like
this is about to be complete abandonment
cutting me off for life completely I
guess I don't know what it comes from
cuz I still talk to my family like love
difficult conversations when someone's
like can we talk I'm like either this
I'm about to cleanse a person or that's
what I'm talking about we're about to
get stronger okay yeah yeah I mean
usually that's what happens and I and I
I will if you'll text me like hey can we
talk I'll go through everything like is
therey something I said like I'll go
through and then I get to a place where
I go I don't think I've done anything to
Whitney that would warrant her cutting
me out of her life forever so I think
I'm okay but there would still be this
yeah this just I think this you know I
think I deal with this with people in my
life too that like I'm never allowed to
get mad at them I'm I'm I'm the same way
I try to avoid these types of
confrontations because I feel like I am
self-aware enough to know when I've
upset someone and when I when I have't
when I don't know that's where I get a
little bit sidelined and I think that's
in my relationship like whenever I upset
my boyfriend I'm never intending to like
it's always an accident and I'm always
like I don't know what I did like I
always say to him like please know that
I've never once intentionally said
anything to like upset like I never been
like I want to hurt him so like can we
just go through life knowing that I
never will do that and I know that I've
fucked up with some friends before and
I'm I just have to like take a minute
and then I always end up like
apologizing and writing like a lengthy
apology I always like write it and then
I take a picture of it in instead of
texting an apology cuz I think like a
handwritten apology means more you do it
the way like men during me too tweeted
their apologies like in the notes app I
don't even write it in the notes I
literally handw write it in a journal
and then take a picture so that they can
see like she like wrote that like she
was trying to be you know she was
actually trying to make an effort here
asides of like I think that this is just
like like me sitting down and there's
some effort there but um I think that
I'm always trying to get ahead of people
being mad at me by apologies but it's
really hard to um we're 40 no one should
be mad at
anyone well said there's really no I
don't have a book for that I don't have
I'm not quoting the stoics like it's
just like what are you do if you're mad
at me like it's the kind of thing it's
like if you're mad at me like you just
I'm kind of done I I I'm sounding like
someone who's terrified of people being
mad at them and I'm I think I am at that
point where I'm like
yeah I'm kind of shitty sometimes like
people have a right to be mad they
they're allowed to be mad at me why am I
allowed to be mad at everyone you shitt
how are you shitty you know I can just
be selfish I can be like Moody and like
I didn't get what I wanted like that to
me is being honest and authentic yeah
yeah I guess I can just be I can be I
can just be like pouty and like I'm
exhausted no one cares about me and no
one's looking at my schedule except me
and every be true is true I don't know
if that's not true I'm like can one
person bear witness to my schedule other
you know like when you have so much
going on and like these people all think
it's you're you're the only project
they're working on but you're it's like
20% of your life and then I just want
one person to go holy fuck like my
assistant is a we do that by the way
every comic does that yeah we all do
that about your schedule does that help
we're all very worried about you that
really means so much to me we we are
very my tour schedule just a second ago
I was like oh my God that that really
we're all worried about your mental Heth
we're worried about your physical health
we all talk about it all the time what
is what are they doing to me yeah we're
all very confused well I'm just scared
to say no to things because I just that
might be the thing that not the thing
that breaks me and makes me more famous
I'm really not clamoring for that it
might be the thing that leads to more
money which I I would like more money I
or it might be the thing I have the most
fun on that I meet my best like that I I
have that leads me in a New Direction so
I just say yes to so too much yes scared
to say no been there yeah triggered
triggered yeah you get it like when you
say no to something and then you're just
I mean are you ever just like sitting
here in your house alone and there's
something going on that you could have
done and you're like yep what the fuck
am I I'm not there doing the thing I
could do it yep I think that the touring
thing is especially tricky that to me is
the most addictive because it's the most
like that is what I got in this for like
into this all four like making strangers
laugh the idea that someone in Toledo
knows who I am and is going to pay money
to give me their night and and give me
the opportunity to like like mind meld
with them for two hour like that's what
I signed up for do you know what I mean
so to me and then also going on tour and
you're go well I'm filming a special in
December so I can't I need to go and
Stage every single night there's no
breaks like I I do think though we are
at a point where we can get more done
like or get as much done without always
going on stage at like super big you
like we can at this point it's taking me
a long time and I need to say this out
loud because I have this like me Dan Ley
Natasha leero like we do these like
zooms where we'll just like work on
jokes and I'm like in my head I still
need to go to The Comedy Store and like
I need still need to go to like fucking
Tallahasse to do seven shows and I'm
like no I know it's funny like I know
this is going to work if I can say this
out loud in front of three Comics I
respect yes can I get on those zooms and
then I can do it yeah come honestly
because that's what I need I don't have
that so I'm still reliant on doing sets
to test stuff out and and I don't like
write outside of because going on stage
L of times when I go and you're doing
like a couple thousand people and you're
like well this person paid all this
money they're wearing a sequin tube top
like they have a vested interest in
laughing at this yeah I've and like the
momentum of like me coming out and I
just I'm signing everything afterwards
or taking photos like am I just riding
the wave or is this joke really working
would it work on its own like in the
belly room at 2 a.m. on like a Tuesday
so I'm kind of like you know cuz
sometimes I really worry because we've
we've both seen great Comics start
sucking all of a sudden when you're like
why are these great Comics all cuz
they're only playing for their fans and
I'm like it's becomes a rally and I'm
like how do you think that joke is funny
you're one of the best joke writers ever
your last five specials were amazing and
you start sucking all of a sudden so I'm
like I feel like I can almost get more
done just like popping in on like a
shitty show where yeah no one's
expecting you to be there and trying
some shit out you know what I mean yeah
that's a good point I just need to jump
on some more I just need to work with
other Comics I I like just if you're
trying to figure out if something is
funny or not like I was like I used to
think needed to get 80 reps in and 880
cities and that was a little bit and
maybe that was true at the time but now
I'm kind of trying to explore all my
self-limiting beliefs I still might be
wrong um the special I'm just about to
put out people might be like uh maybe
you should have done more reps bitch
like I don't know but I'm just really in
ER radical like place of trying to
explore my self-limiting beliefs because
I think I have kind of a lot of them
what are some others around work like I
got to be like I have to write 17 drafts
of this script before I turn it in like
I like I have this thing where it has to
be hard in order for it to be good I
have
saw suful do that and I just like oh I
guess I need to do that I need tost on
Tik Tok four times a week I don't know
if I do like I kind of just like have
these things in my head that I'm trying
to radically like challenge or the
marriage is never for me am I just doing
a bad impression of myself at 25 like am
I cuz fame fame is a motherfucker like
no one feels sorry for people they are
famous I get it but I think everybody
does this it's not just famous people
like how do we stop being the person we
were 10 years ago like sometimes it's
like it's like throwing away that like
you know curling iron that's just like
what am I doing with got hair on it like
you know sometimes we forget to update
our software because it's like I think
it was Neil Brennan that said once he
was like or maybe John Mayor is like you
freeze at the age you become famous cuz
like subconsciously you're like this
worked same hairstyle same cut of jeans
like this is what I do this is how I
talk and you're kind of like this worked
and then you're like well everybody
loves this can I change oh that's really
interesting it's like sometimes I'm kind
of still like saying that shit like cuz
I'm just a piece of shit and because
like I'll never get married cuz like I'm
not lovable and then I'm like I don't
know if that's true yeah I think I'm
kind of just saying it because it worked
at some point mhm I mean but I'm 40 now
it might not be cute anymore yeah I mean
that's exactly what I'm talking about of
this like men don't like me and I'm not
I I I'm they won't settle down with me I
can't get a boyfriend I'm like that
wasn't true it was just that was just I
was just playing a character of what I
thought a female comic is supposed to
say or felt true at the time yeah the
other day my friend was like will you
just St in the mirror like I love you
Nikki to yourself and I was
like no like I know that's the thing to
do I know but that is it that's
embarrassing but you know it's
embarrassing being a fan of Nikki Glazer
and we love you but you don't love no
that's so embarrassing you're calling us
dumb I I know I that's that's always the
irony is that like when when I hear
celebrities say like I can't watch
myself and I'm like but you're expecting
people to go see your movie but you
can't watch it and that's how I feel
about myself and it's like how do I I
know I'm wrong I'll say that I think
people are right I I'm I I wish I could
trust them more and like like I I mean
it's not like I don't like myself I'm
I'm I'm happy with most things but I do
feel I'm falling short in in most ways
in my life and I I'm not I I wish I were
anything else all the time I'd we've
texted about this I'd rather be us
because there are people that move
through the world that we see on social
media every day that they're like nailed
it and I'm like what like I I think this
is why we're good joke writers why we're
good performers because we go like that
could have been better I could have been
funnier like that like perfectionism
like it does serve us a little bit you
know but it's just knowing when to turn
it on and off and knowing when to know
that it's true and when it's false yes I
mean last night like I went to the fboy
island Premiere and like I it was
interesting to me like I I probably
would not have watched it alone I don't
like to I don't like to watch myself I
just start to get too critical and
especially when I'm on camera with girls
that are at ourselves mirors don't
mirrors don't exist in nature it's
supposed to like yeah you're supposed to
see a reflection in a pond maybe like a
little bit
like ice is not reflective so when I but
I was at this party last night with all
these people and I my instinct was like
oh my God like I want to spiral over how
fucking bad I look in that shot like I
I'm a my face is aging it's just there's
no denying it my face is aging on TV
because I haven't done anything to stop
it I think you look better than you've
ever looked that's but it's it's going
what I'm I think I appreciate that and I
there are moments on the show where I'm
like wow you look really stunning like
I'm so happy with that but it is an
indic there are certain scenes where
there's indications where it's like oh
things are changing and this is is going
to happen this is going to this will
start to my face will start to Decay and
things are like I I there was a moment
last night where I like really wanted to
cry because I was just H like I just I
remember that scene I remember feeling
really confident in I felt stupid that I
thought I looked hot like that I would
like walked into that scene feeling good
about myself and like how foolish of you
you look you look you look tired you
look dry you look splotchy you look
frizzy like this is embarrassing issue
this is hold on I'm I really did I was
starting to point the finger of like who
lit this this is a production problem so
my only not for you yeah is that you're
not going like hey can I please see the
monitor can I please see the lighting
can I we apply a filter at the end like
yeah I mean it was I didn't have the the
budget that the morning show has on to
buff out my entire face do you ever see
ree Witherspoon and Jennifer andison on
that show no lines on her face and then
Julian marges they've done nothing to
her sometimes she'll like wander into
their CGI and she'll just blur out
you're like oh okay but it's um yeah it
was just it was it was actually good for
me because I had to compartmentalize I
had to go take that feeling of like I
want to cry I want to start texting why
did this happen why do I look this bad
hair and makeup like why would you ever
let me look like that blaming other
people and I just had to go like it's
not not now's not the time to cry about
this like you're not going to cry at
this party so I tucked it away and then
I like forgot about it like I really did
like I didn't it didn't stay in me I
mean I'm sure there's somewhere in my
subconscious that it's like kind of
lurking and waiting to come out but I
really didn't I didn't give it the time
I like just was like I can't cry about
this right now so I'm not going to and
then I went about the rest of the night
and had a great night and didn't think
about it was alone with myself didn't go
back to it wasn't haunted by it later on
I was just like I did the best I all I
can say is I did the best I could I
thought good I would have never DP
didn't I'm sorry I'm sorry like it's
funny because that like like the special
that I just shot the DP shows it to me
and I was like looked at it and I was
like thank you so much for loving women
so deeply that you think this lighting
is okay right I'm I know you're a big
fan of Steve bushy but I can't look like
him in this special and it's not that I
don't hate my face I don't hate myself
it's just the way these lights are and
the way my brow bone is it's going to
cast a shadow I'm going to pull up a
picture Western European Western
European mut I have bags under my eyes
I'm not going to not eat salt the night
before and starve myself no oh yeah done
with the me hydrating lol imagine so I
do have these under eye bags your it's
your responsibility to make sure they're
not there so that I can go on stage for
you look at it that way I just take all
the blame of like or then I start to
blame my parents like why did you have
sex and you knew you could make someone
like me and that was my line when I was
a kid I used to go why would you make
someone as ugly as me this was the other
on my girl chat I took a picture look at
my fuck look at the lighting on that and
then I zoomed in on my skin texture and
it looks like a cracky Rock like look
that looks like the sonograms that we
okay but wait a second this is another
one I showed my face is like I was like
my this cheek part is just falling and I
zoomed in on it and I sent that to them
and I'm like this is bad why do I look
like this why did I think this was a
good look may I hold on someone posted
this me this here's why because that's
not what you look look like in person
that's not what the hold on no no high
def television captures things the human
eye doesn't capture it's a magnifying
glass okay so this is why so many women
out have riters that are like no no no
we're shooting on film you're not
shooting on this fucking it's called
high definition television everybody
looks fucking insane okay so it's like
and then they put it on these you don't
you can't control what monitor it goes
on you know sometimes you see Pat what
is it called like on a TV when there's a
setting that it looks like shitty like
old video oh the default settings make
it look weird and then there's uh Cinema
mode I was at some like thing the other
night and they were playing It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia and Caitlyn olon
came on the screen I was like I was like
she needs to call her lawyer like the
way that this was shot 7 years ago
whatever this 6 didn't exist so now
she's just under a fucking magnifying
glass she's stunning this is not okay
they need to recolor it for these new
television sort of whatever so it's like
it's not this is not what you look like
in person I always feel like it's my
fault and then sometimes I'll maybe
blame hair and makeup because they're
looking they're the ones that are
supposed to like be like hey she looks
bad and some sometimes I'll point the
figure at them but you're right like it
is it's their job but they but you're
but you're also right in the sense that
people don't see B like they don't think
I look ugly they actually like the DP on
my show like loves me and like thinks
I'm beautiful and like is like so
obsessed with me you're
fired okay they just don't see you
accept me as is then this is going to be
a problem that's the thing is like I I
know what you're saying of like uh you
have to have a talk with them of like I
know thank you for loving me this much
but this ain't it like this is not the
way that I want to look and like I just
I just am like overwhelmed with when am
I going to get a brow lift and I know
this is like such boring like whenever I
come on your show I always sound like I
just hate myself so much and I really I
don't most of the time but I'm just
going there for let me tell you and I
like excavate you pull it out of me in a
good way where I'm like I'm I'm like
processing things with you all the time
um but I I want I'm going to get like a
brow I'm going to like do surgery stuff
I'm going to talk about it when I do it
but I'm like and I like you said I just
want to look like myself and I feel like
when I see pictures of myself I'm like I
don't recognize that girl I don't like
it but I'm like when do I when is there
ever fucking time to do this shit and I
also don't want to go I have to have
surgery so that people so that you let's
let's Okay so was talk texting with my
girlfriend last night she's getting an
eye lift uh or like she wants like a is
that what it's called like a lid lift on
her eyelid yes plastic I will read you
this text like verbatim she's like I
don't know when I should do this I
shouldn't have to do this you know we
get into all that okay good she's saving
the same thing yeah she's like I have to
spend you know 10 grand on this like da
d d and and everyone would go no you
don't have to Nikki you don't have to
this girl but it's like if it means that
you're going to walk through the world
with more confidence and you're going to
feel better about yourself who cares um
so she said so she's like I just don't
know when to do it um and I wrote before
a holiday she went no I mean like should
I wait a few more
years um she's doing upper and lower the
next leap year and I said do it as soon
as it will make you happy okay I don't
believe in waiting to be happy in any
way shape or form anymore you just block
out two weeks of your life honestly a
baby had to slow me down maybe this will
make you take two weeks off yeah that's
a good point maybe this is what it has
to come to you know so maybe it's going
to hit two birds with one sort of stone
literally everybody has done it I I just
wrote everybody is doing anything there
is no need to be a hero as long as it's
safe um I think fillers is where things
go sideways so don't do that shit dude I
yeah I mean that that's I feel like I
still have some filler in my face it's
like weighing it it who who here but
here's what I think it is I like to go
okay if I'm GNA get a little Botox if
I'm going to get this thing I just want
the face I would have had I not had the
trauma and had our news not been our
news do you know what I mean or if I
like was able to sleep 8 hours gravity
being the trauma you're going yeah uh
you're going around the country making
other people laugh sleep depriving
eating shitty food not able to hydrate
you're martyring yourself all over the
place I just want the face I would have
if I like you know wasn't in all these
toxic relationships in my 20s like I
should actually invoice my exes to have
to pay for it that's really interesting
okay cu the shit the stress that's aged
us you know what I mean and no one cares
except us no one cares no one's judging
you it's just I think everything we
think other people are thinking about us
is what we think about us yeah I mean
like but I that's why I wouldn't do your
roast is like I just didn't want anyone
I didn't want like Shane Gillis to call
me old you know like I I didn't I don't
want that was an off limits thing though
we did have no calling women old no
calling men pedophiles uh no oh I
couldn't have done it then that's the
reason I couldn't have done
it well at least the ones that are there
cuz my thing was like if you're a
pedophile you're not going to be here
you know if you're a rapist you're not
going to be here because so many men
right now they're like so you know
afraid you know and then no uh racist
shit uh and no um saying men have small
dicks oh that's great I'm so tired of
the small dick like we're not old like
this whole thing of Whitney nikk you old
you would fuck me in a fucking heartbeat
you would pay a million dollars cash to
have sex with me we're not we're not
doing this so confident we were in The
Writer's room and it was like yeah and
because Whitney's so old and this and
this and I was like you guys am I old
and everyone was like No And I was like
can we stop yeah you know what I mean
comparatively we are though to who to
20-year-olds yeah but I mean I'm just
saying like in some way to children we
are I know but I think the older we get
the hotter we get I'm sorry are you
watching the golden Bachelor no but I
hear firing it's really good I mean even
though all the women have had their
faces done and so it shows you like oh
you deserve love but only if you've had
everyone okay so when I went in one time
because I had this I have really bad
eyebags okay and um I was doing a TV
show and they were like she looks tired
she you I was like i' wait they told you
or did you yes I had to take wait how
did that meting go like who pulls you
aside to be like hey we need to say you
look TI like how does that conversation
please tell me oh my God so at oh God
Rap I pride myself on knowing everyone
on the crew I know everyone on the crew
introduce myself no I it's like I didn't
have a family I make television shows to
like pay people to force them to be my
friends and family it's it's a hostage
situation um I'm the Moss of sitcom and
so I know everyone we at the Christmas
party and I'm like I see someone that I
don't know there with his wife and I'm
like oh this is weird must be someone in
you know I don't know post or maybe it's
some at the network and I go introduce
myself I'm like hi I'm Whitney I don't
think I know you and he goes oh yeah I'm
Kevin I animate your face and
post and I was like I'm so sorry and he
was like oh yeah I I cover up your eye
bags and post and I was like I didn't I
didn't know about the I didn't know that
I was a Pixar character in the show cuz
I would always like look at the show and
be like I look great like oh the DP be
like you're nailing it and then people
would be like oh Whitney's not a good
actor and I'm like yeah it does look
like I wasn't really making a choice
there because you know what I mean and
this is someone they had hired to take
my eye bags out in post production that
I didn't even know about and so then I
learned about it and then um later I had
to go like to these dermatologists who
basically they were like yeah we can't
fill in under your eye bags it's going
to look fucking nuts because your
cheekbones are too you know and then I
don't know where I'm going with this and
why um you said uh oh I forget well like
you have eye bags what yeah that they
were what were they going to do about it
or like what what are you doing about it
I guess that's where it was headed Le
that's what I wanted to know I'm like so
that's how I kind of found out about it
and then I ended up oh basically one of
these doctors was like you can basically
never have salt before you shoot because
of your ancestry because you just hold
water and it's also like fat it's
genetic there's nothing you can do about
it but I don't I had like a point before
that I don't recall I had uh I was on a
show and it was the day of the first
show and we were rehearsing and one of
the guys came up to me and said I just
want to let you know like when you do
lift your arms like there's like a lot
of like swinging up like your arm fat
like swings back and forth and and I was
so skinny at the time like this is 2015
I and I was just about to tell you you
do have a little hair frizz but I don't
know if
care and um just as you were saying that
I was like and I just was almost excited
I had never like heard someone like say
something so bold to me like even if
you're skinny it does it even if you're
thin it does it it's it's one of the
things that doesn't it doesn't really
that's not my thing like so he did he
picked a thing that isn't my thing but
everyone that overheard was horrified he
got fired instant promotion on one of my
sets that what's his name are you Avail
is he available I didn't want him to
necessar I just wanted him to know like
hey don't say that like right before I'm
debuting the first show I've ever had in
my life way to say it like that isn't
like could have been better of like hey
I've worked with actors in the past or
performers in the past where they wanted
me to give them feedback this might be
distracting it might not because if you
are I don't want you to he tried to get
ahead of you showing up at the premiere
going why someone tell me about this
absolutely so that's what I'm saying
it's like you're damned if you do damned
if you don't so I I regret that he lost
that job it it was not my fault I don't
want people to come after me like you
fired that guy cuz it it someone
overheard it he's about to be on payroll
for me so he's going to be fine I love
this guy I don't but that's the thing I
don't really I would be devastated if
someone was like you look old even
though I already know that I do that's I
think I'm always trying to beat people
to the punch I think it's like I think
someone it's the way to go is like hey
this just isn't a flattering would you
like to come look at the Monitor and
then you can decide yeah that's what you
should be looking at the monitor going
yes sometimes I look at the sometimes I
look at the monitor at Whitney and I
just I'm like there's nothing to be done
except surgery and I can't like I like
the thing that I want to fix like some
there was one shoot I did where I was
like I saw the shot and I was like
there's nothing to do like and I was
like nearly crying the whole time cuz I
I so now I never want to see the shot
because it fucks with my head so I'm
just like it's I don't know what then
maybe it's like having some someone in
your corner um like like I know how to
articulate what's wrong I know cuz
sometimes when we just get like lost and
oh my God this is what I look like it's
just going like okay like let's just
like get rid of the Shadow let's get rid
of these eye bags like this is just too
high def let's like Zone and it's like
if you're like instead of doing this
with your arms you're just doing this
with your arms you know it's like little
things like you know I'm able to kind of
like compartmentalize maybe it's just my
ability to disassociate from Deep trauma
but I'm able to like step out of my body
and just go like we have to solve this
or it's something that can be done a
post going hey can we have a $20,000
post
for digital makeup my mind goes uh so
and so doesn't need to talk like this
with her arms like why am I such a fuck
up that I Mar Manos who are we who G
deenus like I don't know just someone
who's super skinny that I'm like why
like why can't I do she's she clearly
has some control in her life and doesn't
binge every so often like she's going to
Pates and fitting it all in and still
has a family I don't even have a family
and I can't like do a plank enough to
like tighten this up like I start going
I go to this crazy place of just like
hating myself for like why can't I be
better like and I went to a Pilates I
went to Pilates For the First Time
because everyone's been saying go to
Pilates it'll change your life and like
the woman was like I don't know why
you're back does this but it like it
won't like you need to like right in you
need to have this be flat and I was
going like I was trying so hard and I
was like I can't and she was like I
don't know why yours won't do it I'm
like can it be fixed and she's like
we'll see and I'm like I I almost start
crying there cuz I'm just like why am I
so fucked up like why and it's such a
dumb thing because there are people in
wheelchairs that are like I can't walk
Nikki and you're back can't like do a
little thing but it was just felt like
uh like people are just like confounded
like why is your like they're just like
confused by the way I am and I think
that's my childhood trauma is like my
parents always being like why would you
say that why why would you wear that
what is wrong with you there's something
WR with you why would you judge a kid
who's just saying what they're saying
why would you look at someone in your
pilates class and say that why can't you
make 2,000 people laugh why what's going
on with you so it's like to me it's like
not participating in the emotional
contagion and like being able to go like
like why can't you do that why would you
say that to me yes you know what I mean
why can't I do that cuz I'm on
planes 80 days out of the year I know
like how about that I have no L4 left
because I've been sitting in a middle
seat on Southwest for the past years
going City to City trying to like make
strangers laugh for five fucking minutes
to escape their horrible lives and
you're an elitist bullshit Pilates
instructor for a fake exercise where I'm
sorry everyone that's in your class is
on OIC and like you this is the most
boring fake madeup bullshit I've ever
participated in you don't have people
like you've definitely gone the Pilates
route before and had people go like it
will change your life everything changes
after you do that's the impression of
them the day is why is not someone I
listen to Hey
Y'all big day big day I get to talk
about Etsy okay the holiday season is
right around the corner and I want to
talk to you about my religion the
website Etsy look if you're like me
you're on a mission to find handcrafted
affordable gifts made by independent
sellers whether you're searching for
custom pieces like cutting boards Linens
throw pillows to give to your favorite
holiday hosts or personal items like
purses necklaces seasonal jackets for
your most stylish friends Etsy has it
now I don't even have to read off this
you guys know how obsessed with Etsy I
am if you're watching everything around
me was procured from Etsy I I live on
Etsy it's my whole life it's my it's my
heart and soul it's everything in here
is from from Etsy the Labyrinth
skateboard the um framed praying mantis
uh any Taxidermy in here is is from that
them the uh bejweled West Virginia purse
the Labyrinth doors all the sewn uh
handm made oh the tiny Tobasco sauces is
even from there um all the crystals all
of the Lisa Frank vintage Trapper
Keepers and binders I could really go on
forever but this is basically I'm etsy's
warehouse this is this where they this
where they ship what you guys buy from
I'm I'm obsessed with Etsy it's the most
original gifts and all my home decor
during the holidays is for Etsy I
started collecting these Russian really
gudy campy uh like bejweled Christmas
trees I'm obsessed with them all these
ornaments I got vintage ornaments on
Etsy and then I got all of these little
stuffed ornaments for the tree they're
like polar bears and little groundhogs
and little like beavers and stuff my
tree is I have a basically an Etsy tree
and the entire neighborhood has agreed
that I have the number one gold metal
tree Etsy is my favorite place I I can't
I don't think I'm allowed to say what
website I don't think that you should
get all of your Christmas gifts from
rhymes with
glamazon but Etsy is my glamazon let's
be honest okay I get everything from
there I even get I get strawberry stuff
Etsy there's this Greek woman that she
free um uh air what is it called when
you um Pat when you suck out the the
moisture from something dehydrate
dehydrate dehydrated strawberries it's
woman she dehydrates strawberries and
peaches and apples and prunes and stuff
H to die for I I literally order this
it's my grocery store too at this point
so here's the thing about Etsy Etsy
turns you from a hoarder to a
collector it's a pretty good slogan you
guys can have that one if you're new to
Etsy use the code holiday 10 for 10% off
your first purchase that is holiday 10
maximum discount value of $50 expires
December 31st 2023 see the terms
etsy.com terms for handcrafted and
affordable gifts for everyone on your
list Etsy has it shop etsy.com I have
the app I'm logged in whatever MVP this
episode is brought to you by buy
optimizers all right so look I don't
think I'm alone in saying that I have
trouble sleeping lately I've been lying
awake for hours not being able to sleep
tossing and turning I mean I can't
imagine what I would be losing sleep
over could it be that there's a vampire
inside me slowly eating my bones that I
might die in child birth in a couple
weeks could it be that we're about to
enter World War III I don't know could
it be the acid reflux from pregnancy I
don't know could it just be the general
Panic every time I go on Twitter could
it be uh being blindsided by four
billion insults every time I look at
something that's about me me on YouTube
I don't know whatever it is I don't
might not know what's
causing my insomnia but now I know how
to fix it every time I started adding
this magnesium breakthrough to my
nightly routine I've been able to quiet
my mind and get the best sleep ever I am
dead serious okay this stuff is a
miracle once I started taking magnesium
breakthrough my sleeve completely
changed now I have no problem falling
asleep and I actually wake up energized
I had taken before like melatonin and
some other things and I woke up a total
Grog Fest and God forbid I talk at a
speed where you guys don't think I'm on
adol for me personally magnesium
breakthrough has helped solve my sleep
problems I sleep like a log I tell you
magnesium breakthrough has been a
GameChanger because unlike other
magnesium supplements that might be
giving you one to two forms of magnesium
magnesium breakthrough contains all
seven forms of magnesium designed to
help calm your mind helps you fall
asleep stay asleep and wake up refreshed
over 75% of the population is magnesium
deficient and what most people don't
know is that even if they're taking a
magnesium supplement they're still
deficient because you're not getting all
seven forms magnesium breakthrough is
the ultimate way to give your body all
seven forms of One supplement in
addition to experience relaxed sleep
magnesium breakthrough also helps
improve digestion this is true support
Muscle Recovery and support healthy bone
density which I really need right now
because I've got a child in here just
like soring up my bone marrow on a daily
basis most magnesium supplements only
have one to two magnesium breakthrough
has all seven for my exclusive offer for
my listeners you're going to go to mag
breakthrough.com Whitney do it now your
body and brain will thank you thank you
buy optimizers buy optimizers Mag
breakthrough so mag breakthrough.com
Whitney and use promo code Whitney
during checkout to save 10% Pilot's like
I love you but like why am I like
hanging from a metal noose for $7,000
like I did I grew up dude there's I like
do you know the my favorite ways to work
out you know those like public gyms that
are outside that is how I fucking work
out there's one on Franklin and Highland
are you kidding me I swear to God
there's like four bars I like a prison
workout I like a body workout a prison
workout I mean I I I played Sports
really seriously I have a lot of
injuries whatever but I went to this
chiropractor um and he was like I'm
hypermobile which means I've yeah your
joints like totally and they were like
you know and who knows what I did with
eating disorders and anorexia and shit
and screwing up my my joints and
whatever um and he was like you need to
relearn to walk basically like you walk
wrong yes see that would devastate me I
went to this Pates instructor and then
I'm like I have like a rubber band and
I'm just like and I was like I would
literally rather be crippled at 50 than
waste my time Andy it felt like I was
learning how to walk again that's how it
felt like in this class like there was
no it didn't seem like a a first step to
things it was just like you're bad at
this this is going to be so hard I was
like hold it like it just felt so hard
and I'm not out of shape and I just felt
like I I go what's wrong with me I can't
I work out on planes I have the bands
yep I work out on planes I put the bands
I sometimes have them here I sometimes
work out during the B and like do yeah I
put the bands over my knees and like do
the like butt exercises and I'm like
always doing like I'm the person on the
plane with the bands and I'm like doing
this it it's great it makes people not
talk to you oh my god nobody's like is
that when he comings they're just like
uhoh then I do that on I'm doing my dad
for doing that no I got dad though once
for um eating three oh yeah I remember
that one that was a
classic you're insane
like like post anorexic meal it was my
like my hardcore keto it was like
Whitney uh Cummings had a Taco Bell like
Bean taco and then I watched her pull
the cheese and pepperoni off of three
individual pan pizzas from Pizza Hut put
it in the taco and then eat it and the
person WR it was
wild I got demad for like putting too
much pepper on a salad and they said all
she did was eat salad with pepper on it
I'm like I would never I do overload on
pepper but it was like it made me sound
like I was some like anorexic like just
avoiding dressing and I was really I
wanted to write and be like I swear I
had dressing but it's like you can't
control that stuff and like it's it is
hilarious when you get caught being just
like a fucking weirdo I don't like these
classes these exercise classes that
shame you or like Soul cycle I was like
going to Soul cycle for a while and like
I love the endorphins like I love the
like heat of it even though it's like I
don't know it's it's still kind of
ambiguous whether it's actually sort of
like you're you can cheat you know what
I mean you can use momentum you can
trick yourself into thinking that you're
exercising more than you are because
they turn the heat up and one time this
guy um this instructor like there's this
the song comes on and you're supposed to
do it like to the beat yeah you know and
he was like Whitney do it to the beat
and I was like if I could do it to the
beat I'd be doing it to the beat like
watching this like SNM shit where people
pay $40 to have people call them out and
embarrass them I was like not not today
bitch like I'm not doing this like I
already feel bad enough on my own like
I'm not going to sign up there's I've
never done classes I don't like it when
people do that in exercise called out
and yelled at for but I also think it's
like we can do that shit on our own like
people overthink exercise it's like I
need a trainer I need a it's like
there's like apps there's YouTube videos
yeah like how do you not know when
you're getting a good workout do what
you did at the in gym class when you
were like four it's just like push up
sit up fake sick and go to the nurse
yeah go running I don't know I just want
to be strong at this oh yeah that's
that's you know what I mean I think it's
more as we get older that's like
absolutely what we need but wait but
your you want to lift your brows up
higher like I just want like when I like
I just want to like I think it's like
the they do like this so it's just like
a little bit of
yeah I think I they gave me the full
assessment of what I need it was like an
eye job I thought about it but I think
like cuz I I love lower I I thought
about it but I just don't think it'll I
don't know i' I've tried but the one day
that I asked my woman to give me bangs I
was like crying 5 Seconds earlier in her
chair and she was like I'm not giving
you bangs on a day you've been crying
just won't do it and I was like oh that
is a really good it's a good call she
was like come back when on a day and
like be in a good mood in N for bangs
and it we'll do it yeah but yeah so I
think that was the right call um yeah I
just like yeah brow lift I think is
there's just too much to do Morpheus 8
yeah te uh micro yeah radio frequency
the threading there's like threading oh
there's something that's like a thread
that goes like behind your ear and under
your chin and like pulls everything yeah
I heard I just this but it dissolves
after a while and here's the thing it's
going to sound you guys are going to be
like oh they're being so insecure
they're being so toxic every woman
thinks like this even if we never get
any of this done like when you and I are
together we kind of just like like Purge
all of our insecurities I really do like
I every time I come here I'm always like
why did did I need to go there it just
sounds like I just hate myself
constantly and I swear I don't like I do
have I remember when I was anorexic and
this woman was like my mom was in this
uh meeting with me with this new
therapist they were trying to figure out
like a cure for me or whatever and the
woman my mom was like we've heard this
is a self-esteem issue and the woman was
like no she does she has good
self-esteem she was like are you smart
and I was like yeah she was like are you
funny I'm like yeah and she was like see
shit's fine I'm like but then I always I
also think that I do I mean my friends
would say you have low self-esteem I
think I I must I don't some ways sorry
it's not my place to weigh and I don't
know the answer please I'm asking this I
think I think we don't have low
self-esteem I think we have very normal
self- flagala thoughts that any woman
any performer any perfectionist would
have and we just talk about it more so
it's like the same thing when they're
like ComEd all comedians come from
trauma comedians are crazy it's like no
everyone's got their crazy shit
everyone's got their trauma we just
advertise it we just talk about it just
yeah I just like don't care about
keeping it in and I think but I think
that there are some people that are like
I don't do that to myself I don't talk
to myself that way I kind of like myself
oh yeah I'm not great at that so what
like I I really can't settle for like
not being best that's not a
winner I mean honestly it's I don't mean
I don't mean to be an asshole but it's
like the to me it has served me very
well in my work in my career to be hard
on myself and it's about knowing when to
turn it off and you and I sort of we
release and admit when we're too hard on
ourselves and that's how we're able to
go like I don't think I need to do that
anymore that doesn't serve me but I
think it's like you and I this is a safe
place for us to talk about it be like I
don't but I come out of these things
sometimes and I and and people will
write to me and be like I'm so sorry you
struggle so much I'm like what like like
people will this is like almost a
therapy session where I'm just I'm
bringing all the negativity right now
but it's not usually this isn't like
it's not crippling but there but I like
to focus on the times that it is because
I think um for me when I was growing up
I didn't hear a lot of women talk about
this kind of stuff and so I think now
when I get in front of a mic it's like
it comes out of me because I'm just
giving the thing that I always looked
for when I was growing up like I just
wanted to hear Jennifer Aniston say what
was like that things weren't perfect and
that she struggles and that she doesn't
like herself some days even though that
that makes me sad because I'm like what
it's not to like but so maybe it's not
it has an aders it's just human I think
it's just like human whether it's like
the media did this to us the trauma did
this to us you know whatever did this to
us you know chat rooms or or chat rooms
comments aim geoc cities I just I think
child people look at us as like you know
I think people as super fearless and
super confident and sort of having it
all and I feel like you and I are able
to just go like yeah sometimes we like
think gross thoughts sometimes we think
things that aren't true sometimes we
have you know um false beliefs about
ourselves sometimes we believe them and
then fall down and get back up you know
and like that's okay I'm having a good
day today so I can talk about all the
stuff like oh I I I can see it from a
third like I'm not in it right now so
it's not sad to me when I'm talking
about it but I realize when I say it all
out it might sound like I'm just like
struggling every day of my life and it
really isn't that but it's uh yeah I I
just um it's it aging though is a
fucking hard thing to do and and see I I
think the difference is cuz I have a lot
of friends Kiren being one of them and
they're all in this chat with me and
they're all women like only a couple of
them are in the show business but most
of them aren't and they just don't have
to look at themselves as much as we do
like they just don't they take like a
Christmas card picture and they like you
know we all everyone takes more pictures
nowadays than we ever used to but people
aren't I don't they don't have to stare
at this the whole time like and have
like look at they don't have to do photo
shoots they don't have to post videos to
get people to go to their Boston show
November 2nd that isn't sold out yet
they don't have to like I just have to
look at myself every day and I don't
think that I would struggle this much if
I didn't have to yeah and and and that's
the problem and that is why when I'm on
set I don't want to look at the shot
like I just don't want another reminder
like the I met a a transwoman recently
who was producing me for a segment on a
show and I was in the makeup chair and
uh the makeup person was finishing me
and she was like oh I'll get I'll talk
to you after you're done I'm like but I
can talk while I'm having my hair done I
was a hair person and she goes I don't
want to look in the mirror I don't like
my and I was like you're so you're so
beautiful you're so bold to have even
made this transition this late in your
life you look amazing but she was like
so scared to look in the mirror and I
really I related to that it made me
really sad in that moment but I was like
H let her just have it like she doesn't
want to look in Mirror I'm not going to
like force her and be like no you're
beautiful cuz I don't think that helps
either cuz when you're in that place you
just like almost want up people to go
I'm sorry you feel that way instead of
like no you're I want I just say I don't
want to invalidate your reality so I'm
just
stay out of this that's really good you
know I like that because it it makes me
think okay she would if she could cuz
she does think I'm fucking hot but I
don't have to hear about it sure sure
like I don't I mean this is I have this
mirror because it's car's mirror from
Sex in the City oh yeah that's right but
I don't have any mirrors in my house the
ones that I do are like fogged over like
there's no reason cuz yeah cuz you walk
by a mirror and you're like like just
unnecessary cutting you know no m in the
house it's uh it's yeah so I think
that's where where it stems from is just
having to review so many photos of
myself and post shit and like after
every show but then also going I had
this before I was on
TV like I had this before Instagram like
I had this like I you know our moms
their appearance our moms and every
woman before them their appearance was
their only currency like I watched a
woman I mean my mom would at dinner put
makeup on with no mirror she could just
do the whole fucking thing dinner she
was always she was putting lip gloss on
me you know like put me into child
modeling she it was just like I just
learned your appearance is your only
currency as a woman you know and then we
get that feedback so I think we all just
have to be like honest with ourselves
but also then gentle with ourselves and
just be like guys will literally fuck
anything like what why like what is the
all of this you know and um you know but
yeah I think it's just like we're just
being messy humans and I think yeah you
and I tend to just sort of like but then
I get I I just don't like the shame that
is put on women who do have um
insecurities about their looks of like
just love yourself it's really sad can't
love because then I start to go no don't
feel sorry for me and don't make me out
to be like I'm some kind of bad example
for younger women cuz I don't like
myself I'm just dealing I'm just being
honest about how I feel n n what am I
supposed to do why and say I love my
curves we have the I don't some days we
have the grandfather we're grandfathered
in so if you're in your 20s and you're
like you guys aren't confident the
reason you guys have self-esteem is cuz
we fucking that's a really good showed
you what it looked like we didn't have
lizo you didn't we didn't we didn't have
a we still don't we lost her recently
but we had her for a you guys had her
for a minute and she made you feel good
and she empowered you but I did not have
women putting their cellulite on display
and like shaking their fat asses and
being like this is empowering I didn't
have that our lizo was Fiona Apple okay
she was a size zero wasting away
cowering in a corner like next to a box
of pizza that she wouldn't eat on a shag
carpet that's like stained with c yeah
Kate Moss and Fiona Apple as our Spears
and I'm a slave for you where she's the
talk about dehydrated she looks like a
like a dehydr like a dried papaya her
stomach to seny um that's what we had I
there's it's really um memeable right
now to like show what we went through in
the early 2000s with how you know
Jessica Simpson being called fat in that
one picture where she's legit size four
Bernie Spear's being called fat at the
2000 whatever M VMAs when she was just
had a slight little may like a fold in
her stomach when she bent over and how
like how did we make it out alive like
it's it's it's nice that some
attention's being drawn to that now
because it does seem like we survived
something to get through that I mean I
barely did I almost did make it through
but you know but like it's um yeah I'm
still recovering from that stuff I still
I can't I can't pretend that it's all
okay and that doesn't mean that I look
at girls who are if I call myself fat it
doesn't mean that I look at a fat girl
and go like ew like it doesn't mean for
whatever Reon I would think that because
my mom used to call herself fat and I'd
be fatter than her and be like what do
you think of me and I didn't understand
when she said it's different for you I'd
always just be like how could it be but
I don't look at other people the way I
look at myself I like uh it's it it's
it's not fair that uh that we can't see
ourselves through the same lens as we
see our friends and I'm not coming for
your mom at all but our mom's like again
that was like she's not listening my mom
used to say she know
how that woman in podcast Jesus Christ
yeah you mean she doesn't know how to
listen to her daughter just in general
or to Spotify um she's listening she
just can't hear anything you're saying
no Kidd um my mom would say all the time
people would be like oh you look amazing
and she'd be like I just have to lose
that last five pounds she would always
say she oh God I'm so fat right now she
would just always say it and I just
that's just so ingrained in my never
heard my mom take a compliment on
somebody gives me a compliment and I
have to go oh I'm so this my people over
your house oh it's a mess like I just
it's I'm just paring what I saw it's
just sort of like I don't even have to
take responsibility for these thoughts
you don't even have to you're like
that's not my voice that's just like
what I saw for 20 years how could I
possibly you know have any other default
wiring dead from like the things and
like that I can even look into the
number of sugarfree gummy bear the
number of alestra potato chips I ate in
the early as it is a miracle that I stop
chewing gum I my my absence is not no
gum like I yesterday I had bad breath at
this party I went to and I was like does
anyone have a mint and this girl was
like I have gum I was like I can suck on
it like I can't chew gum because I
developed sores in my mouth from chewing
gum because instead of eating I would
just gum I was up to like five packs of
trident a day like a smoker and I was
getting sores in my mouth and I'd go to
the dentist and they'd be like why do
you have this and I'd be like I don't
know incredible what that's probably why
yeah it builds muscle in your I mean I
do eat a like I I still eat a lot but
like um yeah that was that was the
damage I've done I mean it's it's TR
like I don't I at this point I think I'm
too old to probably conceive but I
definitely don't think that I put you so
shocked that your body was able to do it
based on didn't you weren't you told
when your anorexic days of like this is
going to ruin your chances I think I
maybe unclear I think I me I was so
young I was like I don't want a kid now
like it didn't matter I was like yeah
ruin my fertility who gives a shit I was
the most Anti kid person I that's the
only reason like when I see people like
I'm never having kids I'm like I was
like that too it's sort of like but when
did you shift you shifted in the past
like few years um a friend of mine when
um I saw her and I was like I'm pregnant
and she was like oh yeah you're 40 and I
was like what do you mean she was like
you always said she's like you told me
at 35 you're like I'm getting pregnant
at 40 I'm never thinking about it before
that you like had that I always was like
yeah I'm going to get pregnant at 40
like and not think about it like should
I do it now should I do it now I always
I mean I did freeze my eggs at 33
whatever that took a little pressure off
but I always was like I'm GNA have a kid
at 40 whether it's adoption whether it's
surrogate whether it's natural whatever
she's like you totally so you never said
never I never said NE I never said never
I think I always wanted one but I wasn't
going to do this thing where I was
constantly perseverating about it and
being like should I do it this year
should I do it next year and I was just
like I'm doing it at 40 and I'm not
going to think about it a second sooner
whoa okay if it happens sooner fine but
like I'm not going to obsess over this
and then I did start getting like really
healthy I started doing like sauna every
day I started cutting out like chemicals
and microplastics and shit and you know
and then I was definitely smoking a lot
of weed so in January I got pretty
hooked on weed in a way that was
unmanageable I did have a manic episode
um but I did find out where some of the
Scientology ships are um wait what did
you go to the center no no I after my
mom died um and I was just in a lot of
grief and I wasn't crying I was also on
birth control which you know look it's
different for everyone now is a weird
time to be coming for birth control
because of what's happening in this
country whatever fine fine but it was
like not for me I realize how much it
was affecting me emotionally I was on
proac which by the way highly recommend
for repetitive thoughts um helped stop
me with a lot of the self flating
thoughts like I'm an idiot why did I say
that why do I look like that like I
think it was 10 milligrams I was on and
then 20 milligrams and after I have the
kid I'm going to go back on it because I
would leave a conversation that went
perfectly fine and be like why did you
say that that was so stupid now you just
text them and say this just try to make
them laugh to forget about that other
thing you said the loop it just closed
that Loop okay and I didn't have to go
like oh you have these obsessive
intrusive thoughts cuz you're a bad
person and you're insecure I was like no
this is just like neural wiring that
served our ancestors really well out in
the bush brush whatever the fuck and
then you were smoking weed and then I
started smoking weed hard and like what
what are we talking hard we're talking
like like adjoin a night to fall asleep
and then at 10 p.m. and then being like
oh let me just do it at 8:00 p.m. then
like oh I'm not going to do spots
tonight start at 4 pm we're just editing
whatever
then it's two three joints a night oh
there's there just the small ones yeah
yeah oh okay someone left that mushroom
chocolate here everyone's doing the
micro doing mushrooms makes you more
creative I'll just take one of those
yeah and I've just gone off birth
control cold turkey and pro at cold
turkey and then I'm scheduling a zoom
meeting with a maritime lawyer about
where the Scientology ships are to find
the kids which by the way okay so Dr you
explained that a manic episode is when
you don't think someone's listening to
well when I saw you I think during this
period you were talking about the Saudis
okay and I said if your friends are ever
talking about the Saudis you might want
to I think that's a red flag I didn't
even know you were what you were saying
about them but I I remember walking away
being like I think she mentioned the
Saudis and I think something's
wrong okay we have to get out of here
I'm sorry that's so funny that was okay
so here's the thing I'm so glad you're
not you're better babe by the way the
fact that you were like well yeah that's
typical Whitney I this is like I mean I
knew something was wrong but I didn't
know it was my place and you seem to be
okay like in terms of you didn't seem
like you were in danger right right
right but I was ination
for I was trying to traffic I was like
you go for a lot of money in
s you know sound of we use that brow
left we can get your PR because it's
like that it's it's like your what
you're saying is true like saudy money
Disney apple and Amazon took Saud money
it is a problem no no no I completely I
I I know what you're talking about like
you latch onto something that is a pro
but it's becomes your it's like I'm the
person that's going to fix what did Dr
Drew say like he he told you that that's
the thing you try to fix it well he yeah
that you think that number one you don't
think people are listening to you
whereas you heard me say that and you're
like that sucks nothing we can do about
it that's a normal reaction right you
know whereas I'm like we got to stop the
ities from buying the entertainment
business because then they're going to
control what Disney stories are told and
that's going to program the next
generation of girls and does any why
doesn't anyone care yeah and everyone's
like well we it's we scroll we scroll
back by seven school shootings a day and
we move on you know what I mean so it's
like this over sensitivity to like I've
I've gone through this before with
crying about my mom absolutely I'm so
sorry babe no please it was like had to
come to that but um but I do think that
you know anyway so that was wild and
then I wasn't like thinking about kids I
wasn't like trying to force it I was
like you know chilling and then just
like got pregnant and that was that okay
wild Whitney text me like okay I know
you have a long day tomorrow with all
this press like you were aware of my
schedule because we'd fit this in and
you're like what can I have for you do
you need breakfast do you need a a
coffee do you need water like what do
you need you're always like the what do
you need I was like I just wrote back
like I don't need anything but you were
gonna be the best mom and you wrote back
I I really I treat Comics better than I
do kids I think that Comics need more
love and care than kids like whatever
you said was so funny but you really are
going to be the best mom I'm really
excited for to for your baby like I'm
kind of jealous of your baby that's
really sweet it's really going to be uh
it's going to be a great situation I
think there is a and I know you're like
not thinking about it yet but there is
something so relieving not that I'm this
is why I'm having the kid in anyway but
it's like of just the relief of the
bondage of self of the like it's really
nice like I don't have to think about
myself all the time it does sound good
when women say that the just like
emotional in the clarity that comes with
it that just people are like do you want
to do this podcast and Van not like no
thanks it's just the answer is just no
to everything mag you're number two now
yeah and it's like my inner child's not
running the show all the time CU I have
an actual literal inner
child and has to take precedent so it's
a lot of things that I'm like I'm never
going to fix this thing about myself or
heal this thing about myself instantly
kind of happen and then you get to redo
your child over again your childhood
over again
you know so we'll see I don't know or be
a total disaster I love you okay I'm
ending this awkwardly because I need to
get her out of here because of course I
selfishly kept you longer than I told
you no I'm glad I'm a liar I love you
okay fboy Island it is out now HBO Max 2
right yes CW no no sorry CW CW okay so
but if it's streaming it's on the CW app
streaming and I think you can find it
elsewhere but it's on CW every Monday
and also something I love that you said
and you can leave and start mobilizing
to leave is like it is a reality show
yes but it's also a comedy show it's
also fucking funny so just like think of
it more as like a comedy show than like
a reality show cuz Nikki's hosting it
thank you w i love you I love you okay
bye don't ride
[Music]
elephants